Você sabia que um fruto do sererrado
pode ser mais poderoso que muitos
suplementos importados? Pois é, olha só
essa descoberta. O piqui, aquele fruto
amarelo forte do nosso serrado, acabou
de virar uma estrela numa pesquisa
internacional. Veja bem, cientistas
descobriram que o óleo dele protege os
rins contra doenças crônicas. E não é só
isso, não. O estudo mostrou redução real
de inflamação sistêmica em testes
controlados. Estamos falando de proteção
para rins, coração e fígado num único
alimento. Sabe o que mais me
impressiona? A gente gasta fortunas com
suplementos de fora, sendo que temos
esse tesouro aqui no quintal. Os
carotenoides e antioxidantes do piqui
são tão potentes que conseguiram
reverter lesões renais induzidas nos
estudos. Isso é a visão funcional de
verdade, usando que a natureza
brasileira oferece. E o melhor é comida
de verdade, não cápsula de laboratório.
Que tal incluir piqui na sua dieta? Pode
ser no arroz, na galinhada ou até o óleo
para cozinhar.